SKRATTAR DU!1!1!11!!!
That's right everybody now to accept this challenge
smash like on the button. Yeah, you know what? Let's not smash like on many buttons. Let's give
Sensual loving to like button.
I Don't know about you guys, but I've been educating myself. I watch the Gillette commercial and
just
Let's make sweet love to the like button. Thanks, right. That's how you accept this challenge now, let's frickin
Go
I'm so ready
Got it
that was awful
This is the greatest video. I have ever taken. Sorry. I that went too fast for me to process what is happening
This is like a conference. Why is she doing a Fortnite Dance all by her?
Oh
It gets it's one of those that gets better the more you watch. Okay?
What is happening?
haha
Am so confussed, maybe some things are better not knowing the context some things Vox
Moving on. Oh god another Spiderman meme, huh?
I Miss Tobey
Tallyho
Watch out spider-man
God, damn it
Pizza time
Oh my god
God, damn it. I don't know if I'm happy or disappointed
I think I am both end up in Skyrim every time every goddamn time I end up in Skyrim
Great meme. You know what? I can appreciate it, even though I lost in life. Stop laughing you idiot
Pathetic. I'm out of G -Fuel. Oh my freaking gosh. I'm out of G-Fuel I could die
No cheating this time boys
Let's freakin go
Okay, hey, all right
You know what at least now I can laugh at it it's so annoying if we're so long
I mean, I don't laugh at it because my health is still intact. Look at my health screen
What is happening
What the--?
This man cannot take any bad words, okay, maybe I should take a break for a while
I'll relive some of my greatest moments
No gotta say this is a pretty legit memes this week smash like no that was a test sensual loving
Frickin Germany
I'm not even trying at this point because I want to die.
Geez guys, I'm down to one health.
God its spider man
You seem very okay the crossover it's happening Kojima-san
Please please I make it happen. Let's start the petition
Tobey McGuire for the next kojim. It was called Death Stranding. Oh my god. Yes, because he hires a bunch of actors
Oh my gosh. Yes, Tobey Maguire for Death Stranding
everyone smashed like smeeeh
sensual loving like on the button, alright what do we got
*one of the GIAEY right activist
Christina Aguilera and others jailed for 10 years. What?
*good morning
ooh
That's a strange one, I'm not sure why I'm laughing no you basically
why are you running
Who says I'm gay
What can I say I got a weak weak spot for dumbass people? I don't know what it is
It looks like I'm negative life everyone. Well, oh, well, I might as well go all out. Just this once
Yes
Oh my gosh
He actually forgot about it
woahh huhuhu
That the moment when you know you're going to die from you
Laugh you lose because you're all out of health, but you still commit to the challenge.
important duty
Mike Pence
Who could it be Mike Pence?
Who are you talking about? This is why I say give more money to politicians
We are not paying them enough.
oh It's Neil Breen. We're literally watching a Neil brain video yesterday, movie yesterday. Oh my god. Yeah, yeah
Jim no
How could he commit suicide?
Who is he talking to?
Who did he tell to call 911?
How could you have done this Jim?
How could you do this
I can't
How could you have
Oh, He can't.. can't help you out of this one
Neal Breen the living legend
Can't pull you out of this one. My hands are tied jim. Sorry. I don't know what to tell you, man
I mean he tried he said call 9-1-1
Anytime I made a video in this movie if you want to check it out by the way, it was a while ago?
no
yes
It's easy
Is this the same guy that was in the water
ok
alright
yes
Damn I felt that very nice message never give never give up that must be the same guy
what is that
So bad and so great at the same time
We did it guys we found the best clip
Yes, I've seen this a million times it's so good
Don't like the caption but everything else is so perfect
Yeah, it always gets to a point. In you laugh you lose right? I lose I basically lose I admit it. Okay
I've been cheating every single time
I don't know if you've got this but G fuels doesn't actually
replenish your health guys, or does it can I say that I meant like in a you laugh you lose context Oh,
Alright guys on that note we're gonna end you life
you lose there if you laughed you lose and if you lose you laughed
So to smash subscribe and I see you broskis. on the next hole ski now ready for this.
"pain sound"
"boop"